si le premier confinement printemps
dernier au moment de pâques et laisse
encore des traces dans les finances des
artisans chocolatiers berrichon à coup
sûr la situation de ce mois de novembre
devrait impacter encore une fois cette
activité pour les fêtes de fin d'année
en pleine période de production
bakou samedi peu particulier pour
l'instant on n'est pas on est encore on
est encore en action on travaille on
prépare on prépare au prépare maintenant
on sait pas comment ça va se passer
concrètement les prochaines journées s
qui va ailleurs un déconfinement est-ce
qu'on va rester cloîtrés pour l'instant
les les chiffres sont pas sont pas très
très bon me reste très optimiste avant
tout produire un peu moins pour ne pas
avoir de pertes
une année 2020 avec -30% de vente mais
une volonté de travailler autrement
travailler avec les réseaux sociaux
travailler travailler différemment c'est
vrai qu'on a dû se réinventer
fini les portes ouvertes et la gestion
de père de famille de daniel avec
l'arrivée à la tête de l'entreprise de
julien le fils qui prend le virage
confinement en mode numérique le premier
confinement veine on n'avait pas de on
est pas du tout présent sur les réseaux
sociaux on n'est pas de compte instagram
on a créé un compte instagram lors du
premier confinement donc début début
mars
et aujourd'hui on est à plus de 5400
abonnés sur sur cette plateforme on a
élargi notre communauté
aujourd'hui on a des ventes sur internet
qu'on expédie celui de la réunion
bretagne
dans le sud de la france donc on a
vraiment élargi notre gamme notre bien
moins de boutiques plus d'internet
au final pour ces fêtes confiné ou pas
ce sera des chocolats encore des
chocolats alors attention à la crise de
foie